[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is novena Naqvi she's here at Yale as
the sing visiting fellow in the South
Asian Studies Council professor Naqvi is
a historian of early modern and modern
South Asia and her research interests
include the Persian ate world of the
13th to 19th centuries the history of
political Islam and the social history
of Hindustani music today we'll talk
with professor Naqvi about the history
of Persian 8th South Asia at the dawn of
colonialism
welcome professor naake thank you so
let's begin with talking about your work
tell us about it
so currently I'm working on a book
project that is tentatively titled
writing the inter Imperial world in
Afghan North India 1757 to 1857 and this
project is centered on the writings of a
set of fascinating actors these are all
serviced figures and by that I mean sort
of mid tier or even lower rung petty
scribes soldiers minor legal officials
and these are people who actually
mediate the very granular processes of
political transition from the Mughal
Empire to the British colonial empire in
South Asia and not only do they mediate
this transition through their service
but they actually write about it in
these Persian language Diaries memoirs
these sort of short historical tracts in
poetry and in letters so I'm looking at
the set of actors and how they
conceptualize political change in this
regional context
I'm curious to know what led you to
study this so I so this would require me
to kind of give you some kind of
historical context that's okay so the
Mughal Empire is roughly from the 16th
to the 18th centuries in South Asia and
British colonialism is formally it
begins in 1857 and ends in 1947 but
there's the sort of overlapping period
which is the 1750s to the 1850s which I
call the inter Imperial period
historians and yeah historians have
broadly
looked at this in terms of the various
claims to these overlapping claims to
political authority in regional context
so as the Mughal Empire is
decentralizing these various regional
successor states emerge as they do in
empires across the world and historians
have tended to focus on the formation of
these regional states what I'm looking
at is how these regional states break
apart in tandem with the empires that
are already decentralizing so it's like
a state decentralizing within an empire
that's already decentralizing and I
arrived at that idea because I was
looking at these regional courts and I
was studying Hindustani classical music
as it was patronized and practiced in
this particular setting in North India
so I was looking at musical treatises in
Urdu and in Persian when I was doing my
research in India and I came across all
these unpublished tracts that were
written roughly around the same period
from 1750 to the 1850s and I really
didn't know who these people were why
they were writing these work they were
relatively unknown figures most of these
works did not make it to print and this
requires me to say also that print
really takes off in South Asia in the
1830s onwards so there's a long-standing
manuscript tradition that survives well
into the 1850s but these materials were
not deemed important enough to kind of
make it to that world of trend so who
are these figures and that
kind of set the wheels going thing okay
so how I am curious now since these
weren't published works tell us about
the methodology how did you access these
works and then also how did you choose
the people that you speak about in the
book thank you so I I started going to
this particular library this is a it's
called a the the ramp or as a library
it's in the small town of rampoo which
is in modern-day Uttar Pradesh
but this also used to be the capital of
of one of these regional successor
states that I'm talking about and this
was settled by a group of Afghan Afghans
diasporic Afghans I should say called
the ROA hilah's and I sort of remind me
of what you just asked yes I'm wanting
to know how you did the research and how
you picked the people that you spotlight
in the book right
and so I I started sort of looking at
quarterly histories that emerge from
this particular context and I was
studying persian at the time and so I
was reading them and as I mentioned to
you and you know I've gone to this
library and I visited it again and again
and again and I came across these
particular works and I saw that they did
not necessarily these figures did not
figure into the formal courtly histories
of rhomboid and the rohila afghans and
so I started asking myself what are the
questions that these people were trying
to address why would they writing these
works that were not sort of formally
recognized as important and I started
realizing that they were important
because precisely what I said earlier
that these are the people who eventually
start sort of entering the early
colonial administration and really
reflecting on what it means for the
formal for the former ancien régime to
disappear and and what it means to kind
of contend with these forms of early
colonial power whether it be the legal
administration whether it be
colonial sort of absorption of military
services and as these people are
entering the ranks and they're making
these decisions about what they should
do what are their sort of options for
employment and for service what happens
to their land assignments they sort of
write in a very sort of personalized
sort of yeah they sort of couched their
ideas in these these sort of regional
concerns of their neighborhood of this
sort of smaller town but they're also
reflecting on on sort of wider political
processes and seeing them in tandem with
each other so it's not just like this
provincial backwater where things are
sort of hermetically sealed that these
people who are seeing their regional
context within a wider context and
writing about it and it's very different
from what you see in the courtly
histories and how things are changing in
the world at that time
can you give some specifics about what
people are talking about sure so a lot
of the soldiers for example who I look
at are serving as and are these South
Asians soldiers yes okay yes so some of
them are naturalized Afghans who've been
there for maybe three or four
generations others are not they belong
to different kind of ethnic backgrounds
but they do
Scizor tools so to answer your question
they sort of reflecting on the recent
past how this regional state is coming
apart how what what that process looks
like so if I were to broadly categorize
the kind of arc that their writings
trace I would say in the early 1750s the
tendency is to kind of write in a
restorationist mode where they're kind
of looking to older empires and
considering the possibility of their
revival or realignment of politics and
how they might sort of enter that space
as they're seeking opportunities for
employment and then by the late 1780s
this sort of turns into an antiquarian
more
where there's sort of recommen with the
fact that the East India Company has
disassembled this regional state and you
see that in the physical landscape so a
lot of these subscribes go about
documenting what that physical landscape
looks like these forts that have been
decimated or sort of yeah really
contending with the physical landscape
and writing in the form of writing in an
antiquarian mode and towards the end of
the period that I look at by the 1820s
and 30s there's really sort of try these
people are trying to kind of see how
they can fit into the legal
administrative regime that the East
India Company has set up so they look at
this through questions of service as
I've alluded to through questions of
customary law through the historical
mode specifically not a universalist
kind of historical mode but one that
focuses on the recent past and what that
means to them okay are there any as
you're looking at the research and the
people's writings are there any
differences of opinions or you know
diverse views on what should be
happening or what shouldn't be happening
mhm yeah so I I feel like there's
certainly it's not a it's not a sort of
homogenous playing field that these are
all different figures and they they they
have different perspectives and politics
I think what sort of puts them together
is that they have a particular notion of
regional identity that they kind of hang
on to and they draw on as they
articulate their views but some of them
are very much in favor of you know
joining the East India Company others
are very reluctant to do so still others
are kind of looking back to the Mughal
ancien régime and saying well good is
there a chance at some kind of revival
so there are definitely discordance --is
also in terms of like who they are
choosing to align themselves with
there's they certainly know
unanimity on kind of okay was there any
extreme criticism especially about the
role of colonialism as it was taking
over can you speak to that at all yeah
there's there's there are ways in which
they especially the soldiers because
this is a heavily militarized context
the early 19th century the late 18th and
early 19th centuries almost everybody
who isn't in a major cosmopolitan urban
center whether you're like a farmer a
cultivator or an artisan you are
possibly almost likely also a part-time
soldiers it's a heavily militarized
context there are all these sort of
independent armed camps that are kind of
offering their services as mercenaries
really to the highest bidder
and so they there's a there's a sense
that the East India Company is trying to
monopolize this context and absorb
absorb all of these soldiers and these
various camps into their ranks and
there's a reluctance to kind of
acquiesce to that process because it
means giving up their independence and
giving up certain rights and so there is
definitely a criticism of early forms of
colonial rule this is not formal
colonialism right that only starts in
1857 but yeah that you definitely see
some of that criticism there and let's
talk about the poetry that's something
you also look at give us an overview of
your findings there so some of the
poetry is written it's not the most
sophisticated poetry I'll say that it's
I mean they're writing in Persian in
Urdu and some of them are writing in
Pashto and these are all languages that
we are sort of associate today with
romance and like high literary value and
and sort of imperial urban cosmopolitan
cultures so I will say that there is
these are not some of them aren't even
written in meter so
that that's the first thing that strikes
you is that some of these figures who
are writing whether it's the prose of
the poetry are either the first or
second generation to come in to
literacies they make a lot of errors in
their writing in in the actual
orthography as well as in the in the the
sort of format of the poetry as I was
just saying so but the themes are
particularly interesting one that stands
that stands out is sort of the sense of
wandering looking for employment from
one place to the other this is again the
soldiers that I'm talking about and sort
of saying well I've been serving in
these different armies but I want to go
back to my water and the region that I'm
from and I want to get married and
settle down that's one so that's what
love means to him he's writing about
that there are others who are writing
poetry about the importance of paper and
how the bureaucratic system that the
East India Company has began to to sort
of in-state weather which is heavily
invested in sort of double entry
bookkeeping and those forms and he said
right so he writes a poem about this
particular figure I'm talking about
writes a poem about the importance of
paper and how you can't rule or get
anything done without having things
ratified by paper so there is very
interesting kind of observations
real-life observations that that that
figure into this kind of form of writing
poetry right right did you look at other
forms of poetry that were commonplace
during that time I mean I'm curious to
know if poetry was a way for people to
express themselves generally or if it
was just really this a group of
individuals that you're looking at oh
that's a great question so there's been
quite a bit of work on some of the the
major sort of ballot rests of this
period people who are sort of very well
known political theorists
sports there's been quite a bit of work
on a particular form of poetry that
takes off during this period so these
people are certainly not the only people
to have this kind of self reflexivity as
well as this perception of their place
in this larger world that's changing but
it's really the fact that it's them and
their context that I think makes it more
interesting but but there certainly has
been quite a bit of work on sort of more
sophisticated literature's and and
Electress from this period for sure
all right so in terms of the political
and social perspectives how did that
change over the trends transition to
colonialism can you speak a little bit
to that yeah so as I was saying earlier
there's this sort of restorationist mode
that you find in their writings that
sort of turns into an antiquarian mode
of reckoning with the recent past and
then that kind of turns into a reluctant
acquiescence with early forms of
colonialism I would broadly say that
that is the arc that okay okay and then
what would you like your readers to take
away I are you still working on the book
is it still a work in progress
yeah so ultimately when you finish you
know what would you like the reader to
come away with your book knowing well
this is actually something that I may
have wanted to say earlier during the
course of this interview but the the the
South Asia occupies a place within this
larger realm which historians as well as
scholars of literature have called the
per unit world spanning you know the
region from Sarajevo to western China
where Persian from the 13th roughly from
the 13th to the early 19th century was
the lingua franca was the language of
administration it was also the language
of sort of a high register of literary
output across this huge region
comprising different sorts of people and
there's been a lot of work on this
portion of cultures it's called where as
what I'm trying to do is to sort of see
how this version at world is fragmenting
with the dawn of colonialism and I'm
certainly not the first person to do it
but what I am trying to do that I think
is original is looking at how these
regional contacts fit into the Persia
net world and how this language and this
form that's associated with sort of
sophisticated writing kind of filters
down I suppose to to sort of mid mid
ranking writers and how it becomes a way
of reckoning with with their realities
rather than with what's going on in the
court and the state of the Empire which
I think scholars of Persian literature
have tended to focus on so I'm really
looking at the place of the region
within the fragmenting Persian eight
world and that's sort of the larger
takeaway that I hope people who will
will sort of focus on and the other
thing if I may also add is you know I
grew up in India in the 80s and 90s
where when regional states were still
sort of fragmenting they have been even
like as recently as four or five years
ago the idea of a regional state whether
it be ethnic identity linguistic or
political identity is very strong in
South Asia
and in the post-colonial context and I
am trying to see how that regionalism
has a kind of longer history that even
precedes colonialism and and sort of
chase some of its and dissidents and I
see that in the writings that these
people produce and so it sort of is tie
to some of my observations of how South
Asia looks like what it looks like today
as well okay yeah well this has been
very interesting thank you for being
here wasted so much Marilyn for your
interest thanks for your question okay
for more information about
fessor Naqvi and her research please
visit our website at macmillan report
yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through the funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at you
you